[Music]
in 4th theater news
what yeah submitted by og JK fan Oh
already know everyday you go to school
to better cook Thai Japanese porn stars
will appear at a live theater show where
they take turns farting on stage that's
so nice
how do they Pat they're fine but these
people do the most interesting things
you know what I mean like I don't even I
don't even know how to propose that to
somebody who's I listen I'm gonna get
porn stars the fart on stage great idea
let's do it well I don't know that in
between yeah you gotta shoot a pilot for
this how do you do that it makes total
sense to me well it seems like this is a
common thing or not the fact that they
okay it seems like there's a lot of fart
fans in Japan because apparently there's
120 million for fans 120 million was a
superstar over there pressures from
females only waning that's like one
third of America this is so true this is
like very representative of the fact
that you should never feel like you're
alone out there in the world because
there is something that you do that you
think is freakish that somebody else
would like to and this is proof
oh is that 120 million around the world
or in Japan how many people are Japan in
the first place people it's like 200,000
pop every two hundred million population
and it's like 120 million that means
male and females [ __ ] love for it
there's 127 million what Wow 90% of the
country is afar fat according to what
there's guys girls grandparents
children's the organizers of the show
are claiming that they want to bring joy
to Japan's 120 million fart fans and
test the women to the limits of their
intestines oh wow so these women it's
not sexual it's a joke well it seems
like they're mixing in a sexual because
they're poor
four-stars there's three women and they
will be so they have things like feature
in this whole show it's like farting
with swimsuit farting with what is it
constantly a huge pageant it's wearing
street clothes I'm horrible because you
know what I pictured what this girl
walks onstage turns around opens up her
butt cheeks farts and then Watts no but
that doesn't work yeah it goes yeah one
of the dog farts is cuz all I picture
was brookey's butthole cuz I see only
when I stare at all the time not on
purpose is because she's [ __ ] just
her tail is up so it's just an exposed
butthole okay I've explained that yeah
so they're they're gonna have this show
in Tokyo at this one theater and it's
all part capital of the world
yeah it's called the show is called
let's all here beautiful girls fart
together they made the show Wow we gonna
have a far choir yeah let's be three
women they're gonna go up and just
Family Guy when Peter was having a fart
off with the guy in the next stall next
to him insert now apparently these girls
out they went on this Japanese channel
called paradise TVs the fart program
back in August and they are saying that
their performance was described as not
skillful but even though they did all
that they're still gonna do this this
particular show in this theater these
other girls I mean it is a talent to be
able to control your fart though yeah
well they are also saying we can't
guarantee obviously so they're just
gonna bring a ton of Mexican food
haven't she looks like she's like they
look like they're they're both Elvin and
Japanese yeah yeah like that like yeah
she looks like she has no oh she's cute
if girl can't see me about combo
Tommy and Julia for some reason like
that's what I saw when I saw this
this photo this girl I'm like nah cover
your tip oh yeah yeah I know as soon as
I saw something like this do you want to
explain yourself young lady I'm no no
comment well rather Giulia fans out
there - um a lot of Japanese porn stars
are to be hard to find attractive
specifically because of the noises that
they make they sound like they're being
killed and I don't want to feel like I'm
[ __ ] my little sisters yes and also
they tend to have how how you say Osama
bin Laden beards down there yeah it's
quite hairy yes there is a fly oh I
thought you were like me - or something
yeah every time they have sex in their
porns they sound like somebody's hurting
them like a squeaky [ __ ] - yeah yeah
what is that culturally maybe they like
it that I think I saw Japanese porn like
once or twice it's like that's not for
me I don't like this I like stinky tofu
I had it once hated it and I tried it
again hit it again and I tried it
another time in a team or I think I know
the reason because I remember when not
you of all people well cuz cuz me just
be researching for JK news articles and
we came across this article the reason
why like Japanese girls like sound like
that during porn is because they want to
sound like an innocent young girl
so it's innocent though it just sounds
really uncomfortable it makes me feel
bad I think that's why because if you're
a virgin it's supposed to be
uncomfortable because it's painful I
don't know what they sound like
it sounds like a innocent six-zero
that's why it creeps me out
Oh young woman you know like it's my
first time bridge and hopes you know
yeah yeah she looks like a [ __ ] 12
year old it's really pretty it sounds
like the end of a Thai person saying a
sentence or something
it's not like a goat sacrifice yeah it
just doesn't sound I don't like it
if baby pterodactyls could speak
Japanese girl moaning that's what is
that that's what it is different feel
for different kids that porn is very
hard to find because there's that and
then on the American spectrum there's
the over actors yeah you know that ruin
the moment
oh yeah yeah you know the overacting I
want it like are you possessed like I
don't like that either you should be
very selective about it it's so hard I'm
sorry I don't want to hear your sexual
preferences no I don't watch porn as
much as I used to though it's like very
few and far between
because I think like once you go through
the whole scope it's like this is the
same [ __ ] I don't need this anymore
once you've seen it and then you can't
erase it out of your head
yeah unless you haven't watched it in a
whole year again and then you watch it
then it's like oh it's like it's
brand-new damn day wait you saw Harney
[Laughter]
it's hard to picture you of all people
because I'm just like all of all of my
friends just have no genitals you guys
said like you I'm a Ken doll but all
guys though Isak just so happened to
show up on your doorstep like I don't
picture any of that so when you're
talking about I looked at the Japanese
boy and then you know what your twins
would just think about this this was
this was a long time ago though this
isn't recent like once once she popped I
was like I don't need to see this in
that's true I found out I was try to use
a Pringle reference but it says the fun
don't stop after saw sight that's not
what I want to say you guys haven't
looked hard enough because there's one
that does it you know there's ones out
there that aren't like the schoolgirl
[ __ ] there's ones out there where women
they look like women and they they [ __ ]
normal and one time I even saw one where
this Japanese girl had like uh you know
like a Brazilian girls body like big ol
boobs straight no no like from Japan I
think they call it like a V porn er I
forgot was it all digital down there
though huh you know they're like they
frickin they digit they blurt out oh
some some was and some wasn't cuz they
were like filming in like a tropical
location
so maybe it was different but I was just
like Oh baby is done for I don't know
American version but there were there
were a lot of girls with like really big
boobs like it was like some kind of like
fetish maybe like huge moves like
abnormal huge yeah the ones that like
Pam Anderson you see like in anime
there's two cantaloupes on this lay
there like double H yeah it's very
voluptuous and then my personal favorite
is like a bloat [ __ ] scenes where the
boobie [ __ ] all I'm saying is you guys
haven't tried hard enough it's like when
you go out to eat stuff right you can't
just eat a taco and say I don't like
Mexican food have you tried the soap bit
have you tried the buttery have you
tried the menudo have you tried all
kinds of stuff like well let that boo
let us wait is that yes I know that was
El Salvadorian yeah I gave it to
Japanese people I mean they're they're
down to explore the entire array of
anything sexual and pleasure like I was
a goner for everything I give it to them
they're open-minded it's us Americans
over here like oh yeah but that's that
porn is just so perverse now to like the
categories are in [ __ ] saying dude
that's like a drug-crazed category what
just even like simple stuff to like the
[ __ ] butthole bow well you uh don't
[ __ ] yes that [ __ ] that's just [ __ ]
into mascara [ __ ] cuz we talked about
it we are in a JK take your party yes
literally porn
Casey likes throw [ __ ] you weren't in
that looks a little like just grab their
[ __ ] face and they blast a pow wow
wow and they barf on their dick yeah
like what the [ __ ] is going on like that
close your throat right okay
so I talked to you about that recently
because we brought it up again when we
threw that episode that take your party
episode I was like so are you still into
that why cuz you wanted to try no really
kind of
yeah when we first met she put extra
best Carol no no not with me buddy
no but yeah that's what I'm saying
though like there's I realized the way I
watch porn was very boring cuz I don't
like any of that stuff
Oh David ha me too I was like what are
you what else are you I feel like I'm a
very boring porn watcher because there's
this whole subcategory of stuff that's
[ __ ] weird this is on the Food
Channel
[Laughter]
late-night you're on your iPod iPad what
some artistic [ __ ] though what does that
mean yes there's certain porn oh the
girl porn the one that DeMint made for
girls no it's made for guys but they
call it women they write it very well
and they choose women that they're
beautiful but they're normal people
that's women porn oh yeah I like women
according you click on women porn they
have the even they might even have music
too and it's like very soft lighting but
can you do like a white room with like
white like curtains oh [ __ ] I like women
point they have Careless Whisper in the
background I don't know names not I I
want to say my one because it has to be
inset in some kind of like big reality
that's me I like 2% real you know I mean
it can't be too like hey what's your
name my name puts Alya this is not gonna
happen in real life
hey guys I hope you enjoyed that episode
of just kidding News and if you did
really enjoyed or if you have thoughts
about what you just watched
leave a comment down below and let us
know and for the next video click right
up here
[Music]